police in Tampa Florida are intensifying
their hunt for a possible serial killer
dozens of officers are patrolling around
the clock looking for anything
suspicious
they're also warning residents not to
travel by themselves three people were
shot and killed in the past two weeks
while walking alone in the same
neighborhood Omar Villafranca is in
Tampa with the city's effort to calm
people and keep them safe oh my good
morning good morning not only are Police
increasing their patrols in this
neighborhood they're also handing out
light bulbs so people can keep their
front porch lights on we've actually
seen city crews also replacing street
lamps the goal here is basically to get
rid of any dark spots where someone
could hide but people here say they're
not relaxing until a suspect is caught
can you tell maybe the audience some
tips are those people who may have to go
to work at night when we have to walk at
night what they can do to be safe
anxious for answers about a possible
serial killer still on the loose we keep
saying one person or we think one person
but isn't this kind of what we would see
with a gang roughly 400 people packed
into an elementary school auditorium
Monday evening to hear any updates from
city officials we filmed him we saw him
walking you notice that person so why
was he not walking it would be was he
walking to a home there are also
questions concerning this surveillance
video showing a man police say they want
to talk to he was walking in the area
when one of the three victims
Benjamin Mitchell was murdered there's a
very good likelihood that someone in
this room knows who's doing it police
chief Brian Dugan wasn't ready to
dismiss anyone in the community as a
potential suspect or even a person of
interest this pains me to tell you that
if you're out there walking alone that
you're either a suspect or a potential
victim every little bit Pampa mayor Bob
Buckhorn didn't hold back in pleading
for the public's help we need you to
call us and let us know what's going on
that's how we're going to catch this guy
and we will hunt this son of a down
until we find them
[Applause]
police are urging homeowners who have
security cameras on their house to turn
over any video any suspicious activity
with Halloween around the corner parents
are worried but the Tampa Police Chief
says this area will be flooded with
officers and even he will be out on
patrol Nora
all right Omar thank you so much